what's up you little spitting kittens
welcome to an episode of this podcast
where we have a guest in today and
today's podcast is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza
beautiful Italian establishment on Pico
Boulevard if you want to if you want to
enjoy yourself and have Italian food
inside of your mouth and body at the
same time you can do all of that gray
block pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard also
this episode brought to you by Ridge
wallet Ridge wallet you carry in your
wallet in your back pocket how old are
you 300 years old get with the times
this new wallet is a ridge wallet and
it's a front pocket carry just a few
items in one wallet boom front pocket
gang son you're gonna live your life
you're gonna have a yacht and you're
gonna have everything you ever wanted
Ridge wallet calm slash Theo also this
episode brought to you by fierce supply
company it's a clothing company and they
have clothing for your body and they
also have new hoodies and sweatshirts
and the links will be below so if you're
running around with no shirt on you can
change all that
also this guest that we're coming in
right now with she is well she's
controversial she's a comedian is she
more comedian than controversy is she
more controversy than comedian what's
going on with this young lady she's
certainly been in the news the past day
and that is Nicole Arbour our board
[Music]
we just want to pray ready let's go
what you just wanna smile get a mani huh
why we even trying don't deserve a raise
I'm about to hit the other night this
way we just wanna pray
ready that's the go get a mani home this
is America don't get you climb another
don't catch you climbing up alright we
are good getting here door hiking here I
Slytherin now or hey today good no I'm
so Gryffindor what are you moving like a
little bit closer you can move it yes
I'm definitely very are you Gryffindor
I'm so Gryffindor I've been tested
multiple times at the Harry Potter
Wizarding World of Harry Potter when
they put the Hat on you they put the hat
on me I've been sorted I've done the
sorting tests online I've gotten a wand
you've tested Gryffindor positive
Gryffindor positive all the time even at
the grand opening oh you were there the
wand shows me are you really a Harry
Potter I'm a Potter head yes yes I'm a
big fan
nice yeah I've been getting into now I
haven't I've only read about three or
four the books reading is a waste of my
time like there's a visual why would I
read yeah and this is a crazy week cuz
you were gonna come in yesterday and
then you couldn't come in I know I'm
sorry it's okay I was gonna come in it
was a crazy week put out one of those
videos that was crazy viral yeah
messages got skewed it was kind of
interesting always interesting yeah true
webs but yeah it's narrowed in today
yeah and I appreciate you coming by and
I was yeah cuz I was watching the view
and I didn't know that you had this
video coming out whenever I'd asked you
to come on the podcast do you know that
or not no okay
I made it in 24 hours so you probably
wouldn't have known that right yes but
yeah so I'll watch the video and I was
just like I guess and obviously there
was some people I got message yesterday
when I was like new clobbers coming on
and people are like would it show I'm
not gonna will this and I'm not gonna
watch you know people just like why
would you have her on you know some
is someone attacked me about it yeah
which i think is interesting which
whatever you know if that's how you know
people want to live whatever but what
was like your thought process with the
video I'm a really big fan I love the
original like I watch I consume so much
everything yeah and this was the first
thing a real long time that I watched it
and I was like oh [ __ ] this is like boom
in my heart like it wasn't to me just
about the theme of black people in
America that got to me cuz obviously I
can't identify as that but it was the
truth I like I think there's so much of
bravery and people being honest and I
felt like it was really raw and really
honest and even him like being shirtless
and the facials and everything about it
I was like oh this is real this is real
I'm like okay well what's real to me
because that's not my reality but I kind
of think that I can show you my reality
and then maybe just maybe I know it's a
crazy [ __ ] idea but we could find
some common ground within our empathy
for each other and our experiences
because I see as a Canadian I see so
much divided that I just haven't
experienced growing up in Canada race
relations are very different in Canada
in America when I came here I almost had
a culture shock yeah really
straight up I was like wow I went to a
hip-hop Club which I go to all the time
in Toronto and I went to a hip-hop Club
here in Hollywood and I was one of two
white people and they were like someone
came out to me a guy and his girlfriend
obviously black and they were like it's
not that we don't know why you're here
we just don't understand why you're so
comfortable hmm and I was like I don't
know why wouldn't have you yeah like
yeah I just wanted to like show my
perspective of growing up as a woman and
there was a lot of other girls that
jumped in and did that too and I think a
lot of people look at me and assume I'm
extra stupid right because of there's
layers to this [ __ ] I'm a bit of a
tiramisu okay and yeah there's imagery
throughout my entire video that people
are definitely missing because I think
they just assumed I wouldn't have
imagery in my video right so yeah the
whole thing was an homage from my
perspective in hopes of pivoting and
making everybody included in like okay
we all have all this [ __ ] let's untie
love our baggage and let's just get
[ __ ] honest meet at the ground floor
and then go up yeah cuz I just I don't
like seeing people fighting about
nothing all the time yeah yeah there's
the idea so that was so that's so like
what was your thought so that was your
idea going into the video yeah you must
have made it really fast
24 hours yeah I mean so you and now did
you came with Mike a little closer
sitting here all right yeah we're
alright did you I mean when you watch
the video do you I mean obviously a lot
of articles saying you know that it has
so much like representation and you know
it has so many somewhat symbolism and
stuff like that did you feel that when
you first wash it or did you just feel
like oh this is a childish gambino yeah
I saw all of it
yeah I saw all of it and like that's why
I like obviously mine isn't the high art
level that his was cuz I had a 24 hour
turnaround which I'm pretty damn proud
of I directed that [ __ ] yeah I thought
it looked look I thought it looked good
for 12 or 24 hours other you do thank
you well I think was just like wow it's
so fast that she must have liked like
did was your thought process like you
know I want to capitalize on the heat of
this video no it was more like in
retrospect if I knew how much bigger his
video was a bet to get cuz I made my own
it was at forty three million views so
to me I know the lifespan of a viral
video or something going big is about a
week right so I was like okay I'll put
this out at the one-week mark and he was
at forty three million views I'm like
okay it's already huge it'll start
declining now on the rise because I was
looking at what's trending and I was
like okay it's at this spot I don't
think it's gonna go higher I was wrong
so I could have like held off and put it
out later
in retrospect definitely but yeah I
definitely wanted people people know
it's the same thing yeah and did you
know people would take such offence to
your video absolutely not
no it's it was hilariously shocking to
me because I'm really good at creating
conversation on offensive topics and
hope you guys like your rabble around me
you definitely rabble
your Rican rabble rouser aroused the
rabble rouser rabble yeah this one
definitely not but you so you didn't I
think that might be what it might be
tough you know to not to I guess it
tough to believe maybe it's just that
like you know you have if you have a
history of rabble-rousing yeah do you
think it's I mean I guess you couldn't
be surprised that people are gonna think
oh this is just a rabble rouser ghin no
I can't I can't I can't be surprised at
that what uh it's interesting for me
because I came out doing I did stand-up
for years and I was a professional
dancer and choreographer I've
choreographed and put his giant award
shows yeah I thought you danced was uh
was spot-on I mean you know I'm not a
great dancer so anything is good for me
but that I thought it was good oh thank
you so for me to turn something around
bigger like a bigger production like
that and direct is things that people
don't even know I do yeah
and for me I'm bored at staring at a
camera and talking to it like it served
its purpose but I'm bored and the live
tour I have coming out has elements of
everything in it and I just wanted to
make something bigger because that's
what I wanted to do and it should be
such positive intention behind it was
there oh yeah and the entire cast and
crew and like hearing people be like oh
it's racist and it's against black
people I'm like half of my cast and crew
are black people right the producer and
the engineer the sound engineer who are
award-winning in their fields are black
people the giro in the hook yeah I
didn't it didn't seem like that to me
I'm not a black you know I'm not black
well unfortunately but yeah it didn't
seem like that to me I mean it seemed
like it I mean I felt like it it seemed
hurried kind of you know yeah it
definitely seemed I was like wow cannot
believe she put this together you know
it's I mean it it looks great it just
seemed kind of hurried it was just like
like were you in our it were you like
and did you have a certain amount of
time you had to get it done in or
something because it's like just really
excited to get it out yeah I thought I
thought that video was going to decline
and I just loved it so much and I just
like the original I loved it and I just
really in this utopia in my mind that I
have created if everybody
put out their version of what America is
like to them we would finally have some
common ground yeah yeah literally
that's the utopia in my mind right
that's uh well we win some we look so
yeah it just seemed like it was did it
feel less like a did it eat I guess it
did it feel like a success then or no
yes because I always want to start
conversations that to me is like if
there's a big conversation starting that
means it needs to happen if we're not
resolved on an issue that's when there's
a lot of controversy behind it we can
have controversy if there's a resolution
on that topic so it's not the topic I
want it to be discussing hmm but a topic
came up nonetheless so I'm doing a video
tomorrow on how I think we didn't stop
racism in America Wow and I have
theories and I think I'm at a cool spot
because I am Canadian and I can step
back and kind of see a big picture and
maybe people will agree maybe they'll
disagree but do you think that if you
were like who can put out a women
because your videos are women's edit
you're like this is as a woman this is
what I see you know this is my like my
childish gambino this is my version yeah
this is of what it's like for me as a
woman or what some of my life is like
right yeah there are things I see or
whatever yeah women's version X women's
experience yeah and a lot of people said
you know I heard that like oh well if
this were a black woman or a Latina
woman that nobody would kick nobody
would have been upset yes like a lot of
what I've done in my entire career with
my let's say dear fat people video
people are like oh well if she was ugly
then no one would care if she put up
this video yeah there would be no
pushback on like other videos I've done
they're like yeah but if she was a dude
and said the same things would be no
issue male comedians have said similar
thoughts carlin did this and like I hear
I'm the wrong look like daily and the
irony is that's in my video too
yeah yeah of course if it was a black
woman or a Latina no one would have
cared no one would have cared I mean I
do think there's a double standard
sometimes that it's like you know um
that it feels sometimes like white
people can't say anything
yeah that's what I'm definitely touching
on in my video tomorrow and I read a lot
of the comments from both sides and it
just feels like I think we're both at
the same spot actually because white
people feel like they're walking on
eggshells for certain reasons it's like
what you say can and will be used
against you in the court of black
Twitter yeah and then on the other side
there's black people who rightfully feel
on eggshells because there's people
being shot for no reason there's rifle
being imprisoned like I can see both
sides but we we have to talk you know
what I mean like we have to get this
[ __ ] out and we have to stop judging
each individual person as a whole of
that group just because of their skin
colour on both sides yeah yeah yeah I
think I mean look I agree mean it's
definitely always good to have a
conversation that's why some people are
like you shouldn't have her on and I was
like well you know it's conversation
like what are we gonna how do we you
know if we limit ourselves from things
that we that sometimes we don't agree
with or things that we're unsure about
or just things that other people said
like this is bad or this isn't how I
like it or whatever yeah then how are we
you know then we're going to be stuck in
our safe kind of universes but did you
think you had to think when you saw that
video that it was you know there's so
much like you know like black attraction
to it like so many are like so much
revelry and excitement yeah that did you
think that like oh this is gonna piss
off some black people I give Charlie go
in there so no not at all
really not it not even for a second and
because it's someone that's controversy
like that year that's kind of where your
nucleus would start
I thought feminists might be the only
ones who come at me like no like what
would feminists be because if it's a
woman's edit what would feminists be
upset about they were like oh you don't
represent us you don't represent all of
us like I hear that any anything I do I
get people being like you can't do that
after I already did it but there are
also so many opportunities for say my
producer or my sound
or the female yeah I thought the cast
was diverse I mean I thought there was
definitely diversity in the castle's
like [ __ ] yeah they were all really
excited because we really didn't have a
really cool genuine message and I broke
it down in a really cool way and there's
so much imagery in it if it's actually
watch does not look at this stupid white
girl yeah imitate or steal or whatever
if you actually look at it like I I did
my best
I did my thing look I thought you did
your best you know I definitely thought
that I thought it was like I mean I
wasn't a huge fan of this song that I
was giving a song like it wasn't like
out of the world with it like I thought
it was good you know better than the
track yeah but I thought the video was I
thought the video was super and it
definitely you know I'm a it makes you
think about things it made me feel there
were moments where I wanted to keep it
on and you know and turn it up and there
were moments where I wanted to turn it
off when I was watching his original
version like you know so I liked that I
liked it like you know it had me going
in all different ways and had me like
you know how I had visceral reactions to
it you know where I found myself like
geez what's going on like in my shadow
why am i okay watching this here in this
place where I'm watching you know I had
some real reactions and I think that was
the point of the video to write for
something like depending on who you were
watching the video he would get a
different reaction out of it yeah you
know cuz I know like coming from a
Latinos reflective too long and this is
a Chris Perez is our producer Chris
Perez it's on now
hello miss Australia yeah thank you yeah
I mean coming at it from a Latinos
perspective I definitely got a different
take out of it I feel then even some
black people did and then some white
people did watch exactly it's up to your
own interpretation yeah so did you feel
like then like I mean do you feel like
you succeeded in representing like
pulled off kind of a woman's edit or do
you feel like you do you feel like you
like that you because you kind of got
like a lot of racial pushback and stuff
to do you feel like you were deserving
to that or that was all just asked you I
think it was well here's the thing
I think everyone gets to think what they
want yes the fun part of art I got a lot
of comments from women who were like
holy [ __ ] thank you you just said that
that I think but I've never said right I
got a lot of that what yeah and then I
got a lot of black people being like yo
I get what you were doing and that was
ballsy as [ __ ] good for you
you did your thing and then I got people
saying you're racist you're white you're
not allowed to talk you're not allowed
to comment on anything that black people
do or any black art and I'm like oh
that's a different thing that's a
different conversation so I think I
succeeded in what I was creating didn't
mean to bring up the other conversations
and it's been pretty interesting to dive
into that stuff but I do understand
where some hurt came from because some
screenshots of different things I've
commented back to people were clipped
really tight and then taken out of
context and I totally see where hurt
feelings can come from that like a
hundred and thousand percent
like I some guy was like what's the
opposite of white woman tears everywhere
and I was like black woman tears
everywhere like that's me just being a
smartass mm-hmm no they just clip that
black woman tears everywhere Nicole
Arbour yeah and I'm like oh [ __ ] really
that's dumb but yeah that's the Internet
associate it's messed up it's a messed
up world out it's a messed up world out
there I mean any you know it's like
anybody can put out anything yeah do you
feel like I think there could have been
more time between when you put yours out
and win his without and you there was no
you had no but cuz I find like you like
rush to get it out it seems like I
thought that it was gonna go down
I saw how fast it trended I just know
that generally a trend like that I
didn't think it was gonna be Pharrell
happy and thought that it was gonna be
big but I didn't know it was for all
happy big so I was like I felt like an
[ __ ] when People magazine wrote that
article recently like it was nice they
were really fair and I thought that was
super cool but I felt like an [ __ ]
I'm like okay now I'm I'm literally
deflecting shine from the original and
that was not what I wanted to do I
wanted to add to it like not to say that
it is like for all happy but like I
loved that one from had that and it made
people feel something thousands and
thousands of people made their own happy
video yeah
did and I just like I don't know I just
I saw something different for it and
Cielo and like I want to believe you
know and I do I want to believe you you
know but I guess I guess you just since
you have this realm of like controversy
that it makes it tough to I guess so
like but you wonder you but you
understand that though yeah it's funny I
was doing an interview with Yahoo
earlier today and she's like well in
sama in Santa Monica I'm just on the
phone like we did okay I did a bunch of
interviews today and the one with Yahoo
was interesting she's like oh is this
like you were trying to just get
attention for this I'm like no I was
like I was just doing some art yeah I'm
not I'm not at level 12 piss people off
all the time and when I am pissing
people off my core fans definitely know
it's always to get to something real and
a resolution every single video I've
ever done if you break it down like
let's say you the most controversial of
dear fat people it's like I was disabled
for six years I barely walk and then I
would see people doing things to their
bodies and like abusing themselves and
self-inflicted pain and I'm like ah I
wish I could do what you're doing right
now like I wish I could go out and go
running and you're eating garbage and
you're killing yourself and you're in
you're eating your feelings and you were
logged up you were stopped you're so
shut down it's stuck yeah and I was like
we need sometimes you need a drill
sergeant
sometimes you need a hug yeah I felt
like people to snap the matter that
needed a drill sergeant and if someone's
dying at which I felt like a lot of
people are on that topic it doesn't help
to rub their shoulder you got to get the
[ __ ] paddles and shock them yeah and
be like what are you doing so that's
like what I did with that one
for each video like I treat each thing
differently depending on the topic but
it's always with the hopes of a
resolution and like that's just keeping
it [ __ ] real yeah yeah do you feel
know me more and I think I'll change
your mind okay yeah yeah and maybe it
takes a minute I mean I met you on Jim
Jeffries podcast you know we did that
together like a couple weeks ago yeah
and I thought you were extremely funny
right and I didn't know about you know
any I I didn't know that you had like
this
you notice you had this kind of
controversial kind of vibe you know or
sometimes this controversial trail that
kind of follows you I still think it's
funny ya know I know you do I know I
know you do and I look I think there's
all types of entertainment I mean I
thought that your video was I was like
wow this is impressive like how how did
she get this you know how did she get
this done and so fast I mean it was so
fast because it was what 48 hours after
his came out or something well it was a
week I was a week a literal one week oh
wow okay I have recorded it a bit sooner
I had like one day to kind of tweak it
and stuff but it's cuz I produce large
scale things all of the time yeah I
don't know like 90% of what I do right I
work with amazing brands I have a whole
other life other than yeah those things
in the comedy and yeah so for me to call
up some dancers and some other people
and say hey guys I have this idea it's
positive you had a lot of support I did
and like the people in it there were
reporters in it there were the people
from Playboy Radio in it there were like
there were a lot of real cool people and
everyone had a great like a positive I
behind it so I'm sure like to pull that
[ __ ] together we had a big team meeting
at the beginning and I'm like I want us
to remember our messages here why are we
doing this why are we doing this part
who wants this role have you experienced
this okay you can do that right like we
were a lot went into it yeah and a lot
of thought you care yes I hope I hope
you watch it there's like you know I've
watched it a couple times and I mean oh
it's interesting you're talking about it
I mean it's like you know there's
definitely a thing out there where it's
you know where things get roasted on in
in Twitter and in these weird worlds
where it's you know it's it can be a lot
of bandwidth I mean obviously there's so
much bandwagon
you know finger-pointing and hatred out
and out there yeah you know on the web I
mean I felt like probably a lot of
people were I think maybe people's
upsetness that's not a word but it is
yeah could come from just the fact that
it was so close to that like I think
people were still trying to live in this
world of this video and learn what it
was about
and then yeah I could see how somebody
who like oh and then some white woman
and took it from us you know but yeah so
you understand that I understand it
right the intention and I think it's a
human beings right at some point we do
have to just be human at some point we
do is just have to be human beings and
it's like you know if if we're all going
to be equal then we'd also all two seem
to be equal you know I understand that
and yeah if you weren't a white woman
would people have looked at you the same
whatever they have been as upset no I
don't think so no the answer is no and
the funny part is like I've been
discussing this like with my team and
again we're we are a funny Bunch it's
like every shape size color race yeah
and they're all like Nicole you're
you're used to this people always assume
you're stupid they assume there's no
intent behind anything you do yeah
that's a look I can relate to those
things you know that's the same thing
people think a lot about me a lot of
times you know yeah I mean it's just you
know it's just it's certainly
interesting so interesting but now so
how do you find this though this is
where I struggle like like are not
struggle this wrong I'm wondering how do
you go from controversy to comedy though
that's where I'm like well how does this
contra comedy because if people show up
and they are you know if people are like
miffed yeah if we can use that word yeah
then how are you gonna you know how do
you then it seems like you're bringing
them a far-away back around to get them
to laugh well that video wasn't supposed
to make them laugh like that being in
particular nothing I'm just talking
overall like how do you go from
controversy yeah it's a cut well my
other videos aren't my other videos are
comedy videos and then yeah I put real
points in there it's like the real shits
peppered within it yeah accidentally
made you learn ha ha and then I just
like do my nonsense so that's easy and
then I do live shows and I put the real
[ __ ] in there and I just like I like to
secretly teach people things or make
them secretly think about stuff but
something like this like I don't know
I'm gonna navigate it yeah cuz I do want
to be going more of that direction to
I'm gonna be doing more
politically-charged
[ __ ] I want to talk on real topics I
don't want to be a one-dimensional
one-trick
just be funny only cuz I have more to me
and that I actually love that about
childish gambino yeah of his different
sides like he does stand up he does
acting he does his music he I that's who
I am
I have to start letting that out I won't
be happy as a person right yeah I'm not
worried about it
ya know I don't feel like you're worried
about it I you know well I guess I maybe
that would have been a next question of
mine like yeah did you have some
reservations after like I'm sure there
had to be a moment or two where you were
like because I would be scared like the
internet sometimes can be scary to me
like I remember one time I was dating um
you know I dated like this lady that was
on Real Housewives Oh a couple years ago
or something right and suddenly it was I
was at the gym and it was like on the
bottom of the ticker and I was like what
the eff like and I wasn't even like
super really dating or you know like it
was just kind of whatever and then I'm
like [ __ ] and I just remember being like
I don't like this like I want to be an
entertainer yeah but I whatever this
other thing is happening out here where
it's like there's this press and there's
this opinion or and this stuff that's
forming about me that I have no control
over mm-hmm that's not based on my
talent I didn't like that at all
it felt extremely I remember calling my
manager about can you just make this
stop somehow like just make tit like it
was on everything it was on everything
and and that was just super scary
um so I'm sure I'm sure you felt a lot
of like some of that like when that kind
of thing rises up yeah so like last time
I had tons of college I have a kind
controversy a bunch of times
yes the first time I was not ready I was
not ready and I was literally disabled
still an on disability when I filmed my
first video that went crazy viral that's
why I'm sitting in the white wall I was
sitting in bed so it was that for large
people daddies that was that was my
third okay super viral video was dear
fat people okay yeah but that one when
that one went crazy viral I was still on
disability so I was like oh [ __ ] I'm
getting press it were you on pills or
something no I was on everything for
like years
but you remember making it and
everything like it
yeah no no that's 100% Nicole no but
that's the cool then you know I mean
like I was still in pain and like I
would make that video so different now
but uh yeah I was like oh [ __ ] I better
get up because here's I'm on a roller
coaster whether I like it or not so I'd
let her show up to this stuff and it was
crappy it's like you don't know what to
expect and when people are saying things
that are untrue about you and I've had
people pretend that they're dating me
I've had like I found a whole bunch of
that stuff that icky feeling of like I
don't know let's focus on like the thing
I do
it feels pervasive almost and I don't
like it either but this time around when
that started happening I didn't
anticipate it like that but I felt like
I was ready because I know I am now and
people and this is gonna sound so
after-school special but people calling
me a racist doesn't make me a racist
right I agree with you it's a good point
I mean there's so much witch hunting out
there these days
and it's a lot of it's just immediate
it's like people don't even know they
have no idea because I you wouldn't you
know I mean I don't know you don't I
don't know you didn't strike me as a
racist person you know the video didn't
strike me as all at all his racist yeah
it wasn't you know and I mean I feel
like I feel like I would know a race is
pretty easy because I've you know I grew
up in an area there's a lot of racism
and I feel like it's I mean I felt like
yeah it's kind of messed up that you
know it is tough is tough for these days
for a white woman have a voice it's
tough yes are some white women anyway I
don't I love your terms but I'm gonna
sit cross-legged yeah you know I'm not
comparing my in quotes struggle to other
people but legitimately I feel like I am
not allowed to be a intelligent be
talented unless my clothes are taken off
which I address in my video by the
dancers being scantily clad all our
professional ballerinas but it doesn't
matter because when we show up on set
we're supposed to be in thongs and be
twerking like we are really put into
these boxes and I just I can't live like
that I can't give a [ __ ] I have to do
what I'm here to do and what I'm called
to do well I don't know what you believe
in up there but when I have
ideas and larger concepts and I'm being
called to do it I have to do it I got to
do do you know like do you risk I mean
do you feel like was there a fear this
time you're like [ __ ] I'm gonna lose I'm
gonna lose my whole audience like I'm
gonna lose no there wasn't like I think
you have those little like waves of like
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
but that I'm like no you're good you're
good this is not a real thing people are
intelligent they'll know that I'm so
thankful this time that like people I
thought was really fair and Perez Hilton
of all people I thought was really fair
which is cool cuz he wasn't so fair to
me in the past but like he's changed a
lot in like the past six or seven years
I remember yeah having an interview with
him a couple of about six months ago
Nath he was a lot different than he used
to be a long time ago isn't that fun
though how we like we get to change and
I think we have to allow people that
ability to change yeah we have to give
people room to a [ __ ] up cuz if we're
all living in a world where we're not
allowed to [ __ ] up or experiment
especially when we're all [ __ ] up
anyhow right yeah express your [ __ ]
Asst yeah like yeah I think we all have
to just like loosen the reins a little
bit and I think that will happen more
when we start having real conversations
and being honest because yeah it's weird
I think of someone like Justin Bieber
who grew up with that kind of like
scrutiny on him and or Chris Brown that
you know he makes a mistake that of
course it's a it's a bad mistake what
happened with him in Rihanna but for him
to have to live in that forever it's
just not fair it's not it's not real and
I think we gotta like riad ress how we
are treating each other kinda what do
you think um but do you feel like I mean
some of your stuff that it did it treats
people
I mean if like I like say like the fast
shame video like is that like a joke or
is that real just like your real
thoughts and it's well that's like go
into character mode right definitely a
character yeah it's a funny character oh
thank you it's a hyper version of one
part of my brain yeah yeah but that
served its purpose like I got thousands
upon thousands of people and I still get
them daily being like you saved my life
I needed someone to I watched her video
and
I went oh [ __ ] she's talking to me yeah
and I lost X pounds like I'll show you
the photos and my fault
I believe you our producer said he might
be fair he said he might be fat the
other day was John man I just barely
found that out someone brought it up to
me that you might be fat yeah yeah you
know it's actually funny cuz my weight
fluctuates a lot and my best friend read
this article of some guy who texted his
friend that he was fat every day until
he lost the weight and during college
and finals I was stressing out and
eating a lot yeah he texted me every
single day that I was fat and it kind of
did help you know I know comes out of a
place for love you know he did I guess
fat shaming me a little bit I lost the
weight and then I think this past year I
started putting it back on again what
happened there was somebody died in your
family like how what made you feel like
you put it back on like well you know
I'm like a stress eater yeah you know
and I actually used to be in really good
shape I saw a good competition I would
watch that stress eater delicious yeah I
played football all throughout high
school I actually box most of my life
and then I broke my shoulder playing
football and that kind of limited I had
like multiple surgeries that kind of
limited a lot of what I could do and
then I don't know if you know anything
about boxing but we had to do a lot of
weight cutting so I was always on diets
and food is delicious yeah it is and I
hate having to like lose you know when
you're cutting weight yet to lose like
15 20 pounds in a day you know talking
to a model so you get it so after all
those like well I don't I'm not gonna
box anymore I mean I used to want to be
a professional boxer and that's just
that completely went out the window and
I was like wow I'm just gonna eat
whatever I want to eat and what about
know whenever you saw the fat shame
video that were the show I mean I don't
know if that's I mean I saw that when it
went viral you know it didn't bother it
didn't bother me in the slightest cuz
one I understand that it's satire you
know I totally got that and it helped it
I thought you were funny Thanks you know
I think comedy if you're funny that
trumps a lot of things you know like and
then I could see how some people would
get offended it's just I'm not somewhat
I'm just not gonna get offended by that
you have a different experience and I
know what I mean like I grew up in such
a multicultural neighborhood and I was
watching The Simpsons and I
with in an Italian neighborhood but
going to school with trainees and
Jamaicans or my friends and like
Filipinos and like we all roasted each
other everyday yeah yeah so I just yeah
me too that's what it was like growing
up by people didn't care as much it
wasn't it's crazy it's like I don't feel
like in a lot of ways that we have gone
I feel like we've gone forward as people
I just feel like electronically it's
like we're still we're living in
different centuries and we keep bringing
those different centuries up into
current times a lot of times yeah
because I think we're evolving as people
I just feel like on social media a lot
of us aren't involved or we're just it's
just easier to hate there it's easier to
be angry there that's why I turned off
some calm my comments I turned it off on
YouTube on this video and I turned it
off on Instagram the second I saw my
cast getting like super harassed and
hated on yeah did they feel bad then
because I noticed some of your cast
didn't share the video so they all did
it first and then I was like yo fall
back I'll take this heat like this was
not what we did this for so fall back
and some of them are like no we're
putting it out send us more clips and
like a bunch of them posted even more
after that they're like we [ __ ] that
we know what we did we know the
intention you're not doing this by
yourself and I'm like it's okay I got
this was there a difference between like
if like black girls or white girls or
Latino girls that were that were more
willing to share it or was there any no
no and the producer the guy that
produced the track Quinn Anthony badass
friend of mine for years now he did some
interviews yesterday like I said he's a
black guy and he went to bat and he's a
very intelligent very philosophical kind
of man and he was like you know how are
you calling appropriation on Nicole you
know let's say for example Whitney
Houston's number one hit is I will
always love you
created by Dolly Parton so he's like
it's not cultural appropriation she had
a great idea we went in this vibe she
was appreciating the original it's a
remix and then where's he from
is he from from here I believe yeah I
think he's an LA native and yeah like I
have a whole bunch of big music
producers hit me up and all black people
after and were like yo that was dope we
see what you were going for the tone of
your voice is very fred durst it's cool
there's no
that sounds like right now yeah that's
record do you feel like what did you
feel like the video is so outside of the
race thing then right outside of that
because yeah I felt like I was like this
is just seem like such an easy thing to
accuse people of all the time now and if
we can't all just do whatever we want to
do and it's I feel like we almost can I
feel like most people are kind of doing
what they want to do yeah
like when I look around like most people
it's like I don't see as much I mean
there's certain things are certainly not
as races the environment that I grew up
in I don't hear anything like I used to
hear when I was a kid yeah I mean you
know what the problem with calling
everything racist is it it takes away it
from it you know like my for my family
first emigrated here they experienced
actual racism you know like and and to
say that you're racist because of that
video is the thought it's it's like
infuriating do you think it was a
message right but do you think it was
now people could definitely get lost
here I feel like this is a place where I
got lost with it yeah I felt like where
was it comedy or was it trying to make a
statement I don't think there was comedy
in it I think there was biting satire
hence the smiling to the camera while
I'm talking about rape yeah you know
what I mean like that's my art that's
that's how I feel about it I'm not gonna
cry about it I'm gonna smile and say
[ __ ] you to the camera while I do a
video while the girls being carried away
by a Mexican man who he had actually
gotten the date rape drug I think he
said three times three times himself it
was multiple people and then I got in
that so that to me is the way I express
myself like it's it's biting and it's
satire but there was no haha funniness
to any of it yeah yeah do you think then
so I guess like as an entertainer are
you gonna be able to get people do you
feel like you still want to be a
comedian or do you feel like you are
trying to go in a different direction
because I feel like it's gonna be hard
to get people from controversy to comedy
I think you can go from comedy to
controversy yeah but I've been doing it
like it shows all the time
huge tours offered right now and I'm
gonna be doing them and I'm really
excited and I'm gonna Nicole Arbour it
yeah
not gonna just stand there with a mic
and tell jokes cuz that's not where I'm
at right now right there's gonna be a
lot of everything and when I think
that's some inspiration even watching
the childish gambino video I was like oh
wow like this is something that if
you're an actor or you're a comedian you
can do this also if you want to you know
if you feel it and even watching your
videos like oh wow this is brave like
this is you know she has on tap shoes
like that's something you can do if you
feel it yeah talk about the tap thing
real quick yeah cuz there's some serious
irony to that tap scene look I always
wanted to be a tap dancer I will teach
you so yeah we'll learn that's actually
really fun oh there's the irony of that
part is I was like you know what I want
to do a nod to cultural appropriation
but I've been taught it since I was a
kid so I realized that tap comes from
the minstrel shows and went to
vaudeville and I know that because one
of my like huge inspirations and then
teachers was Gregory Hines who's like
the notorious tap man of the world black
man for those who don't know and growing
up as a kid he didn't say to me a little
white girl you're not allowed to do this
because it's for us he just made sure
knew the history of it so growing up I
knew where it came from I know the music
that it started with like I freaking
love tap I don't care if it sounds lame
I'm a big fan yeah it's me and super
neat that's why we put that in there and
I'm like well here's three white girls
that grew up learning tap and it's not
because we wanted to culturally
appropriate or steal it's because it was
taught to us and we loved it too so I
threw that in there as a little nod to
the cultural appropriation which looking
back now is [ __ ] ironic yeah well
mean if we're all out here some of this
sometimes cultural [ __ ] I'm like
this is just I mean if you want to look
back through the history books like
there's it's all been everything's being
culturally appropriated somewhere along
the lines you know did you yeah thank
God it doesn't come from white people
originally I think that it would have
been a lot worse I think I would have
been here I think it would in a lot
worse do you but you have to know at
some point like this is gonna push some
buttons buttons I'm not scared of
pushing buttons I'm not I'm not
yeah be uncomfortable yeah I my favorite
jokes and the things that I see in the
world like I love George
and he pushed buttons he did I love it
it's something what stuff you can't do
it that much anymore but do you think
it's not like say you're doing the tap
dancing you don't think like oh this is
because there's some you know like you
don't think I'll peep this is gonna get
over AC I love tapping yeah where is the
line when do I get to live my life I
love rap I love hip-hop
I love tap dancing I want to mash it all
up I love being super white as well you
realize I have mayonnaise
I will bring goddamn raisins and put it
I don't give a [ __ ] it's precious yeah
it's like when can you do it yeah yeah
it's like how can you live your life in
a world where it is tough to live your
life in a world where things are you
know created by everyone it's like you
can only use white stuff I don't even
know what that is anymore right does
that mean no little black girls can be
ballerinas cuz that's stupid right cuz I
know where that came from too it's it's
dumb I just think it's dumb and we all
need to like oh I don't think it's a I
don't think any of that kind of stuff is
helping us I just don't think there's a
solution to it there's definitely a very
stupid double standard no cultural
appropriation
I don't even honestly get I don't
subscribe to that rule I think it's the
dumbest rule ever come being Mexican I'm
the first person in my family to be born
in America and I think I just I don't
understand the negative part about
cultural appropriation I love it when I
see black people open up a taco stand I
think that is the best thing ever
because they want to share my culture
they want like yeah I don't mind that
stuff and it's I think also in you know
Japanese culture is the same thing they
like it when people share their culture
so I don't understand when I see another
group of people like say no you're not
allowed to use my culture that that goes
against everything that I was brought up
I feel I feel why they do it too though
because they still feel oppression it's
not the same approach from 200 years ago
which is another tweet I got in trouble
for when there I said a sick of people
talking about slavery something along
the lines of it's over let's focus on
the socio-economic slavery of now which
I'm gonna address in my video because
it's true I mean what they feel right
side so yeah I mean yeah that's
it's tough too it's like you want me to
tag black girls when I wear braids I
don't know right but if someone could
give me some kind of playbook that there
isn't a real playbook I mean a lot of
it's so vague and it's based on how it's
based on what articles people want to
write them and what how upset people
want to try and get people and there's a
lot of people tons of people who sit on
Twitter sit on social media and do
nothing else to contribute to anything
they're professional victims they're
perfect yes that's a big thing it's
going on in America I agree man if all
these people that are hitting up my
Twitter went out and voted for whatever
cause they want whether it be a large
presidential thing a local thing of what
a municipal thing yeah [ __ ] we could get
things changed yeah imagine imagine they
got a turned voting into like online on
Twitter make it like American Idol no I
think we're close I mean I think we're
really really close you know I think I
mean everyone says that the rock is like
running for president is just leaning on
Rosen for running for president next
time so I could easily see it being
something like that you would save us
all on YouTube and woody Kanye Kanye
said that he looked crazy last time I
saw him though I'm ready oh I'm ready I
guess man like Breakfast Club yesterday
was making fun of me donkey today I'll
take it I think that's a I'm talking
about me makes me very happy
so but how do you go from that so people
talking about you right but do you think
that like the long term of it do you
think it's a viable like being
controversial it's but that's not the
goal right well is like the goal is real
[ __ ] right there's so much water down
[ __ ] I can stand agree there's a lot
of water down [ __ ] I can make jokes
like about anything and keep them within
the realm of safe and get laughs my soul
doesn't like it I did it for years
yeah like I don't think that I was in a
car accident and spent years in bed to
come back to not live what I think is
gonna be what I'm here for so I know it
sounds a little bit Kanye ish but I have
to do what I know to be right is wrong
that's your perspective and I think I do
it I'm not worried I'm honestly like I'm
just not worried yeah about it yeah
people see Who I am yeah let her
actually following right
indeed so do you feel like this new this
next video that you have you already
mentioned is racing as some type of
racial element yes and I'm doing a
roundtable with all people of color and
all these people kept saying you don't
know you don't know you need to listen
people say that a lot of times to me too
and it's like why does someone
understand something yeah like I don't
know yeah there's some things I don't
know for sure
so I'm saying come talk to me I'm
setting up a round table yeah be me and
I'm gonna sit there I'm gonna talk about
[ __ ] I'm gonna tape it I'm gonna put on
the Internet yeah cool you want to talk
let's talk
yeah sometimes the best conversations
the realest conversations are had
off-screen that's the craziest part
chair you know chair because it's the
only safe place to have conversations
now is when there's no cameras rolling
when you can just speak your mind so
yeah what is that like you guys know
Olivia to follow you after but it is you
know it is it is interesting how you
know it's like you know do you think
sometimes has just been in such a way
for so long that you know maybe black
people feel I mean you can understand by
Google's perspective though on when they
when when people were upset with you if
you if there were black followers or bi
people on social media some of them I
mean obviously there's a lot of Muppets
out there I don't care if they're black
or white or [ __ ] blue who just follow
the who have never had a yes we're just
a bunch of [ __ ] goldfish no matter
what they just you know they're just
swimming in their bowl that's it yeah
but do you feel like could you
understand some people's from the video
I think it's really misdirected really
misdirected if they take a second to
think about it I don't think like a
remix video should be met with the same
fire as someone who has shot a kid yeah
like and that's what came at me which is
I think it's ridiculous the tweets that
were taken out of context hundred
percent a hundred percent see how that
could hurt feelings
ruffle feathers totally if people don't
like my music this time people don't
like my work I don't give a [ __ ] yeah
like cool that's opinion yeah but uh the
other stuff yeah but that's not the goal
so we'll fix that yeah and I ain't
scared that's good yeah your feet I mean
you definitely feel so Goods brave you
know
thank you that's what I'd like Eminem to
like not that not to compare myself to
him but imagine what he went through
just cuz he loves the art of rap and
hip-hop is like the soul white person
that was really pushing through all that
what he's been called what he was like
and that was in real life too when
people would beat him up for coming to a
show like yeah that's crazy if I look at
people who've done like way bigger [ __ ]
than me and I'm like okay if they can do
that I can be brave yeah I can just put
on my suit and walk through the fire
look I mean it's it's uh is definitely
it was definitely brave you know it was
super brave the bravest thing yeah I
mean it's like here's uh you know do you
feel like it landed where you wanted it
to or D feel like it was awesome I feel
like it landed where it had you yeah
like I'm a big everything's happening
for a reason kind of person and then you
see where it is and then you learn from
that you adjust the dial and they keep
going yeah and yeah because I Know Who I
am and I know the goal is never to just
hurt people for the sake of hurting
people cuz what the [ __ ] the point of
that yeah I think there's always room
for me to learn and adjust and tweak
things but I was really I felt pretty
good cuz like my whole team stood behind
me even when I was like no get the [ __ ]
back let me take this heat right they
were like no we're with you I'm like oh
wow that's cool thanks guys do you feel
like there's like that you can get that
with that much like people like having
do you [ __ ] the media treated you fairly
kind of yeah you do yeah because well
it's the media that's cool you don't
have people yeah I'm not a big fan a lot
of times so flicks by a sensational
headline right that is their job so I
literally feel like this is the most
fair I've been treated we'll see we can
see what Yahoo said after because it was
a really fair conversation so we'll see
what they report after but I've had
people completely twist my words or
full-on make up things in the past that
didn't happen this time if the black
press want to say I suck I'm whitewashed
am i I am so white I am the whitest of
the way no you're not shocking me but
call me mayonnaise that's fine
say that that's cool yeah but I think
people I think Perez I think a couple
others were super fair I think the
political websites that actually broke
down the frames of my video with his
and they caught what I was doing I was
like that's cool like after today I
probably won't ever want to talk about
this video right yeah no I know it's
fast it's like things come and go quick
you know the next this next video you
have coming up what is this about
I don't wanna title it yet but it's
definitely about fixing racism it's like
white girl's gonna fix racism in under
five minutes
Wow I have a big idea and I think that's
what everything is about like I have a
bunch of like TED talk kind of stuffs
coming up to you and I've done talks
like that in the past and I [ __ ] love
it I love being able to flex my
intellectual muscles and then go back to
comedy and then go dance and like do all
that stuff so there's gonna be a little
bit of that in there tomorrow it's gonna
be comedy mix with a bit of my preaching
and then uh yeah so just a convent is
Nicole Arbour holla yeah do you remember
that guy guitar that was on the internet
do you know that guy Brian no he seems
fun though talking about he was oh no no
he's on Instagram for awhile and he
always had like these ABS and he was on
drugs but he was like damn he was like
nah but is he single
he is definitely saying oh he got
tattoos are like doves or something on
his neck damn yeah when they cry he was
big on vine I remember now I'm trying to
cuz he did yeah he was like holding the
got that time yeah that's all he did and
then it just went crazy like the way he
did it I'm trying to remember his name
but I know I know exactly what you're
talking about now cuz he had like kind
of like long hair a little bit and then
you would ya the titties to line I
thought was really good oh thanks you
know these are my titties that is my
tool yeah thanks good job dad as I told
you brain right oh yes and it's so God
like I know this is your comedy podcast
but it's just so no it's okay it's not a
comedy on here okay I was feeling bad
for you talk about a lot of real stuff
oh yeah yeah yeah no so not just like
usually like the Monday episodes more
comedy and if we have a guess and it's
just like about just like life you know
or just like about what's going on or
like what makes you you know what makes
us feel like we feel or do
what do you think do you think you're
something you're past that makes you
okay or comfortable like in the like
having even controversial role because a
lot of people don't want that at all you
know yes and well I've been like this
since I was a kid I was always in
trouble because I would ask questions I
got kicked out of class at private
Catholic schools so many times because I
would stand up to the teachers when they
would say something I didn't agree with
so they told me gay is wrong it is in
the Bible that it is wrong it is a sin
and I was sitting beside my gay friend
and I could feel him dying on the inside
and I was just like no it's not I was
like nope I'm like there are examples of
being gay in the Bible I don't think
it's wrong plus if you think it's wrong
Jesus would forgive you anyway
so ha we're good and then they kicked me
out of class and then I did my is you
which takes you an entire semester to do
on all the ways I found people being gay
in the Bible and all the examples oh
yeah there's a lot of gay activity
everywhere
they wouldn't even especially long saw
the interstate and that's true fine
I remember when I was um in high school
they had a man I met I was a busboy and
he was a bus man he should have got been
a waiter by them but he was still Boston
and this general was a buddy of mine you
know and he was you know homoerotic man
and he and we became friends we used
steroids and we'd pull off the side of
the interstate and shoot steroids in
each other's boxes yeah and it was I
mean it wasn't like I mean that was my
broke top what's a broke top Mountain
Brook back mountain that was my
Brokeback Mountain was me and this
Italian dude just gonna stare Roizen in
each other's butt cheek says chill you
know as well I was a busboy he was a
bust man but um
yeah that was probably oh so yeah anyway
crazy [ __ ] happens off the interstate
what were we talking about were you
talking I don't know but that was a
great story so I don't care yeah and he
died actually shut out Billy conforto he
died he was on pills and he drove into
an embankment oh my goodness yeah I've
lost three friends two embankments dude
whoa that's crazy
we should start a fund yeah yeah there
should be something that we were talking
about I'm just always kind of been a
rebel like that I also do you feel that
need to write to like
I feel the need to do what's right all
the time like but do you do you always
trust your idea like do you have a do
you feel like you have a solid scope of
what's right yeah I do
and when I do when it's not right and I
do it anyway it never works out well oh
yeah yeah when I force something when I
don't go with my gut
all of it like yeah and then being for
me being in a car accident and like not
being in the world really for so many
years I've done a talk on this for
people who might have seen it I
literally made like a deal with God I
don't know who you believe in but I
believe in the Lord
okay well that guy I was like you know
if you let me come back I promise that
I'll bring as many people with me as I
can and like be real and I do my [ __ ]
for real this time
not just pose and be pretty and be a
model and stay in the little box of hey
cute white girl this is what you're
supposed to do with your life which I
was doing before so I was like no I'm
coming back and I'll do it I think's
right and yeah that's why I talk about
drugs in one video that one's super
viral I know that America North America
is very over drugged yeah experienced it
myself when I could have gotten real
treatment I was just given pills like I
I just kind of feel like I see different
perspectives on [ __ ] and when we express
those we can help people yeah well yeah
I mean I look I think it's always good
to have different perspectives and yeah
I mean I appreciate you coming here and
thinking about you know some of this
stuff with us and you know sharing kind
of you know breaking down a little bit
because yeah there's just a lot of heat
out there you know there's a lot of heat
about you know just about the video and
just what people thought you know I want
to say this too I think this will be in
some articles but for people listening
that are like oh you stole this from him
and you're using it for what am i using
it for he gets the money from it like it
was an instant
label deal yeah gently and they get
money like a remix they get the money
from it yeah so it is making money on
the YouTube side but that goes to him
right rightfully so we said that in
advance someone was like oh well what
are the song splits on this I'm like
this goes to the Church of Gambino right
like this is a donation yeah
and yeah it was just it was just a piece
of art being expressed and that's it so
there was no like thievery intended or
I'm going to steal his viewers it's like
how you're giving me way too much credit
how am I gonna steal any anything from
that I'm surprised any shine came this
way from that yeah do you feel like it's
that being and not even from America
like a Riesling from Canada that people
give you an even tougher time to come to
America and then like discuss like you
know or comment on what's going on in
America not that you're not allowed to
whatever but do you get any kickback
from that sometimes that's why I put the
line in there like we'll say North
America okay yeah
I say yeah I was wondering about that I
feel like it's similar there's a lot of
similarities but there's definitely the
race tension the racial tension is so
much larger in America it is larger here
that's why I want to have the roundtable
and sit down it's like you don't know
you don't know okay teach me like now
what like teach me I would love to learn
because I'm pretty good at finding
solutions I find a lot of black friend
like if I have black friends from other
countries that are not from America they
have they don't have a stuff of time in
America um you know like my black
friends that are from Jamaica or black
friends that are from England so yeah I
don't know I mean this is the look
there's a ton of you know there's a ton
of there's always conversation to be had
it's always good to hear different
peoples for different people's
perspectives Chris do we have a couple
of calls that came in for Nicole yeah um
we got a couple pulls them up right now
I really like your shoes you do those
Tom's yeah yeah and Tom's I say they buy
a pair for you a pair for somebody else
yeah for something but I've never met
that person know anything like that they
should put a thing in to see you know if
that's real I want their photo I want I
want to like see it
sorry you're doing your producing job so
this first call is from orphan orphan
what it what's up do bound calling from
Chicago means orphan what's that boy
thing home just want to say what's up
and buses to all of you out there
listening okay I'm the Nicole Arbour
thing I love the fact that she came out
and blasted all fat people cuz I myself
was fat at one point and got the courage
to lose all the weight and yeah
and yeah there's no need for anyone to
be big guys we need to get off our asses
motivate ourselves a little more well
yeah
nicole says yeah you know that because
she made the video I know that like like
I mean I see a lot of people you know I
started with addiction oh a lot of
people that you know for some people
it's an addiction you know some people
are addicted to snacks
addicted to you know having bugles
having you know pies pieces of pie
leftovers other people's leftovers you
know that was something yeah my buddy
said hi I'm like 3.14 repeating yeah no
people like having real snacks
late-night snacks mid-morning daytime
afternoon nighttime I used to date a
girl she would wake up in the middle of
the night and put a bunch of jelly beans
and chocolate chips in her mouth YUM at
the same time but bad yeah so anyway I
know it's an addiction a lot of people
have to do you feel like sometimes your
are this one-off this without this is
that it's just it's it's more it's just
kind of a surface level it's not gonna
like do you feel like it can't help
because there's just so many more little
like there's more to some of these
problems no it does help right I am a
catalyst and I know it to be true and I
have millions of literally millions 700
million people have watched my videos in
the last two years yeah and millions of
people have reached out and been like
that thing you said that time changed my
life and I'm like what when yeah so like
you know I catch the meet sometimes I
don't care because I turned around and
go wow I helps all those people's lives
these people were in chronic pain
they're getting better treatment these
people over here they're not on those
unnecessary drugs these ones they're
getting along this relationship is
better
that's all game winning right yeah yeah
I guess well I'm a cheerleader like for
real that's a good point
I'm there's so many ways to reach people
and if you know yeah I mean it's like
who knows how people can be reached
right some people may need you know
hand-holding and some people may need
you know something real fancy and then
some people may just you know that it
may just need to see somebody just shoot
them straight in a video and that's what
I mean there's no Universal answer no
yeah and then
sure that like you said it's helped a
lot of people but I could also see how
some people would be like it's not for
me yeah that's the difference of let's
say we're hurt because we're all hurt
right yeah and all my videos stem from
like okay I see a problem let's fix it
so if I'm hurt you might need physio for
the same thing that I need a painkiller
for the same thing that you just need to
go for a walk until your muscles are
better right so I just think it's
different pills for different right and
I think I mean if it helps one person
wait and why should we not do that thing
yeah well you know what we definitely
been a place it's like yeah we wanted we
want to find things that offend us you
know we want to be offended there's a
lot of people out there that wake up
every day and want to professional
offense yeah it's gotten out of hand
sometimes I think we got one more coffee
okay yep let's go to it of calls okay
and this next call is from Scuba Steve
it was Steve sounds familiar
scuba Steve down here in Houston Texas
and I had a question for Nicole Arbour I
wanted to know if she could tell us more
about her depression and then also about
the myths legends of the Hollywood
casting couch I understand that they
also have a casting recliner casting
loveseat or could be so kind who is that
your daughters with more details on
scuba Steve yeah yeah who's a doll
that's right thoughts on that Nicole
well depression yes
very large parts really came out when
after the car accident when it came to
fruition through that stuff that's what
it was stemmed from but obviously
depression is a multi-layered beast and
I made a video on how to defeat and
treat depression which also went psycho
viral people thought it was very
controversial as well because I told
people you can get better and a lot of
times people don't want to hear that and
I do believe that that can be true you
mean look yeah it's kind of almost like
shock therapy a little bit someone what
you do do you feel like that yeah
definitely but like when I
comes the depression mr. Scuba Steve if
that's your real name is probably not no
it didn't seem like it was real man I
mean it seemed like a real man but yeah
I'm a little if he's the actual Scuba
Steve it'd be cool if he was yeah I gave
people like three steps like and I
really think that like our mindset is so
important like our mind is like the
strongest tool we have so if you believe
that you're not going to get better you
will not and I guarantee you and the
difference between me and a bunch of
people that are being treated at these
crazy chronic pain clinics at the same
time is the main doctor said to me do
you think you will get better do you
believe that I can help you with this so
if you don't leave he's like you won't
he's like you are already working
against all these odds and I switched my
mindset put sticky notes all over my
whole house that said you're getting
better every day
you can do this you look great you're
awesome like everywhere I could look
stopped watching negative [ __ ] only
watch positivity I do three sermons a
day that I listen to online or what are
I listen to motivational [ __ ] every
morning and when you start actually like
dealing with your real stuff then you
can get better you gotta be real to
defeat suppression you can't just take a
pill and expect that you're better yeah
yeah you got to deal with the real [ __ ]
could you understand how if somebody saw
one of your videos and they it did not
work for them you could understand how
they would be upset I mean you could
understand how people would look at a
video like oh that's you know you know
that's mean or something you could
understand it
I can understand it but that video in
particular I give it a hundred percent
Nicole Arbour stealin [ __ ] yeah well you
come back to me after you try the things
I told you and tell me they didn't work
and I'll tell you're full of [ __ ] yeah
like I firmly believe that you can
defeat depression I think everybody can
defeat depression or at least treat it
to where you have a way better life and
yeah that's again like and that's a
funny video and people oh [ __ ] that's
funny and I'm like yep but I gave you
yeah look there's a lot I mean some
people don't wanna hear things you know
and there's a lot of stuff on the
internet that people I mean that's one
thing about the internet it's like it's
full of stuff that people want to hear
and stuff that they don't want to hear
yeah it's interesting huh yeah it's
interesting it's fun watching people
react I think yeah like yeah what do you
get out of that like antis
yeah that's what I am to me I'm like
yeah I'm a funny social scientist but do
you feel like you like does that get
addictive in the way you're gonna have
to up the ante like if you have the next
video is about how to cure racism it
sounds like I just don't know if this is
gonna go over well I you know it's okay
I think the other ideas have to go out
there these ideas are real concepts real
thoughts and they need to be out there
and if I thought them and they shouldn't
be out there then I probably wouldn't be
inspired to do it because just looking
at my history it's like all of the times
that I say the things that I'm really I
really feel a lot of people get helped
by it whether I have to stand and fire
or not so I got to do yeah well I mean I
guess it's brave I mean if we stay if
we're here and we don't say or try and
if we don't share what we believe we're
supposed to share yeah then yeah I mean
that would feel [ __ ] up you know a lot
of hope you're on a good track Mena you
know hope that the long-term picture is
is is good you know I know it is yeah I
just like I don't believe that I could
come into like I've done this so many
times it's like what am I at I'm over 55
super viral videos now Wow at the first
one people are like yeah that's a fluke
blonde chick showed up second one yeah
okay she couldn't do it again fourth one
was dear fat people five six seven eight
I'm still going in
I had like 12 in the first few months
and then people like goes still a fluke
I'm now I'm like okay [ __ ] you it's not
a fluke yeah I just like I I have a
message behind what I'm doing I have a
list of societal issues at my house on
my whiteboard and I'm just gonna cross
them off here comes the next video hope
you got something from and what gives
you the right to be able to do that you
think this obviously you just have a
voice in anybody can yeah yeah yeah I
actually think we have a responsibility
that if you see a problem and you know
how to fix it you think you could help
you have to do that muscle yeah yeah
yeah they look it's mild it's bright I
mean you look you're super brave yeah
huh I mean I think you know I don't know
sometimes I feel like I maybe do like
bravery in some areas you know I like
bravery sometimes it to speak about
certain stuff or to think about certain
things
um
I don't know I think I'm still learning
a lot about myself you know isn't that
fun it is pretty fun it look it's the
best it's like yeah and if you don't
take some risks and you don't do things
and where do you end up yeah you know I
mean you just end up not knowing you
know you end up probably not I mean you
the only way to get out of a fishbowl is
to be you know kind of you know tempt
your fin and some other water you know
you got to kind of see what's going on
so yeah I mean it's definitely you know
a super brave you might be that maybe I
mean you're the first female guess we've
had is that right Chris yeah I win yeah
yay yeah you might win Thanks being here
yet
good luck with the video you don't know
the name of it yet I don't yet but
there's a bunch coming up and then I'm
working on the live tour right now so
tickets will be available very soon and
it's the show is so funny it's insane
like yeah every single time we have a
like a meeting on the show we're going
through the script I'm crying and then
everybody's crying and I'm like oh this
is fun and what type of is it just a
one-woman show no there's a full cast in
it so there's like there's myself
it starts out one way and then we take
you a totally different direction but
it's funny as [ __ ]
and super topical and really interactive
with social media and where could we see
that work could we buy tickets we're
gonna be touring everywhere but you can
just yeah not yet unfortunately but
we're gonna be going to across the US
and Australia and UK and obviously I
have to go to Canada
cuz who do you like in yourself to like
if you had to compare yourself to like
another artist you know oh I'll just can
be no good yeah specifically the last
few days probably um like I I think or
this is just something new that we're on
I'm on some new [ __ ] but like I think
I'm a mash-up of a Tony Robbins with a
Carlin with I think I'm an old school
entertainer where they used to do
everything like a Dick Van Dyke hmm
that's I think I want to sing and dance
and act and write and be funny and do
all of the stuff and I have motivational
stuff coming up - and I haven't
even know why pigeons would sit in holes
that seems stupid [ __ ] lazy man no no
no well well I appreciate you coming on
and those are some big names there's a
big name to you that you listed and you
know yeah it's a I mean look up the
politicians - yeah I think they're so
brave literally yeah I do like you can't
be a politician without being willing to
stand in the fire and like I really look
up to Michelle Obama recently like Oprah
to me is like everything yeah I know she
has to a lot of people I just think
she's so honest yeah multifaceted and I
just think it's cool that yeah she does
everything and then like Michelle Obama
she's just like she took that job that
she was given and she fricking ran with
it and she ran a home and she ran a
White House yeah scenes and you know
that her husband was busy but she kept
that [ __ ] together and you know that she
was there for him and she started all
these really cool initiatives like and
she still is such like a model of what
you can be I just think it's really neat
yeah yeah I thought one of the greatest
things that I've seen probably in my
life is uh was probably having like a
like because if you're like a black
child growing up like you and you look
at like the White House and you've all
or you know you see like Oh a black man
can be a president then it totally just
changed your perspective like I used to
think when I was young and they had they
had commercials for Disney World on the
television and it was always white kids
at Disney World
really yeah and I was like [ __ ] it's so
like I just sort of thinking like black
kids can't go to Disney World like you
know well just because that's what the
commercial showed us you know it's like
and they probably weren't you know
thinking that way they were just
probably thinking this is the clientele
that come you know like yeah but yeah
it's just wild it's like especially the
things that we see and the things that
you know that we see or you know they
can really inspire people you know and
like jay-z and like I love business too
like I I don't know all of the
directions I'm gonna go like I have some
feature films right now that people are
you know aiming to buy for me I have
live show that I'm selling to Vegas
that's a crazy ass show that I think
people are gonna really enjoy I just
have so many different things a lipstick
line coming out I'll get lippy like I'm
doing lots of stuff and a lot of
aspirations yeah yeah I'm doing them
it's not even aspiring like they're
happening right now they're all in
motion and I look to someone like a
jay-z or like a Diddy who they started
with the music or if I start with like
with the comedy and then you spiral it
out all these other things it's just so
fun yeah well thanks for coming in and
talking about us with the video I'm
super curious to see how the next one
goes yeah and she's uh so nervous I am
oh yeah you're nervous about to my next
video I can tell yeah I wonder if I am a
little bit I just I guess I'm stuck
somewhere in between like she's
definitely brave and just how like it
what it feels like to have that
controversy because I don't feel a cuff
it's for me it feels so what that feels
uncomfortable to me so for you to be
able to wear that it just is like it's
interesting so my friend that was in
here earlier Olivia I know her Olivia
beautiful young lady I thought as well
so single mother isn't she no yeah but
yeah we'll go with that I'm her baby she
was in Wonder Woman and she's in the
video too and she was in the movie
Wonder Woman she's one of the Amazons
and we were both talking the other day
about that scene in Wonder Woman where
there's fire going on on this side and
there's fire going on on that side and
there's like the dead zone in the middle
that nobody will cross and I'm like ah
[ __ ] it I'm taking off my clothes let's
go yeah like I just get that that little
moments of okay let's just Wonder Woman
this [ __ ]
yeah and we'll see do you feel like you
have anything to lose or no I think what
I have to lose is my self respect for
myself if I don't do what I am inspired
to do I mean yeah and if people yeah if
you don't do what you feel like you can
do if you don't try then I mean no
matter what it is you're probably it
just it probably doesn't end well for
any of us you know you gotta be brave
yeah she's viral girl thing she is viral
always um
Nicole thanks so much for coming in and
hanging out with us thanks for having me
mister yeah I appreciate this was random
or fun
and we'll put all her links to where
she's headed below Chris anything else
no that's it thank you for coming in I
appreciate it was nice meeting you nice
to meet you too and again I love your
beard thank you so much appreciate it
you